[Music]
and we're hearing from Clark County
School Superintendent Dr Jesus Jara his
yearly address happening this morning
from Resorts World some issues he says
he'll tackle include low School
attendance and the racial graduation Gap
Joshua peguero was there and joins us
live from The Newsroom Joshua another
big issue teacher vacancies how did he
address that so Vanessa in his state of
the school address superintendent Dr
Jesus Jara says CCSD is determined to
improve grades and graduation rates he
says the district will not settle for
average students despite the state
making it below average investment in
education he adds that Nevada hasn't
invested in early childhood education
and the silver state ranks 49th in the
country on pupil per teacher ratio the
district is also struggling with hiring
teachers having a significant number of
vacancies most of the openings are in
the areas of the valley where
predominantly Black and Hispanic
students live
teachers have choice right so then we
have to work within our bargaining units
to then provide more incentives
um you know the work may be different
and how do we incentivize Educators to
want to go into that so we're having
those conversations right now according
to the Clark County Education
Association the district will need at
least 14 000 teachers over the next 10
years superintendent Jara says
Partnerships with Nevada State College
will help the district produce produce
its own teachers at five house CCSD will
address the low attendance reporting
live in The Newsroom Josh peguero eight
news now